this may be the biggest story of our
lives and there's questions about
historic moments in our lifetime that uh
may be bigger you know 911 being one of
those moments we were just talking about
this before the show and uh Fair Point
fair point I understand but this this
could be
I don't know maybe it's a little bit
hyperbolic but this is this is a
dramatic Revolution this is a dramatic
change Donald Trump is facing
136 years in prison let me say that one
more time Donald Trump is facing after
his arrest his his arraignment
136 years in prison
now I can't imagine this going anywhere
Beyond where it's already gone because
this is a ridiculous charge what's
happening even CNN has come out and said
this is underwhelming there's nothing
new in these charges it's exactly what
everyone said it was going to be